Ancak
[Müzik]
bundan
neden bizde
sabit olan birçok
Evet
Ey
ve xavi
Evet
Y
Hoşçakal
[Müzik]
kız arkadaşımın gittiği yerlere
Ey
bana söyledin
[Müzik]
Y
Bence
ve
[Müzik]
Y
Evet
[Müzik]
perez
Evet
[Müzik]
x ile
ile
[Müzik]
sonra
ekstra değer
[Müzik]
James
Mart
[Müzik]
kendim
Bence
iyi
Evet
[Müzik]
s
Anlıyorsun
bu adam
aylar
[Müzik]
Evet
klüpte
Hayır
[Müzik]
Ne
Ey
Y
[Müzik]
şimdi
çoktan
[Müzik]
Böyle
Y
kullanım
[Müzik]
sahip olmadığın için
Evet
[Müzik]
o zamandan beri
Ey
ve bu kadar
çelik
[Müzik]
Evet
eğer varsa
sonra
sonrasında
[Müzik]
ve burada
Evet
Ben
[Müzik]
m
yang
[Müzik]
vizyon versiyonu
ve milyonlarca konuşma var
[Müzik]
Y
nasıl idare edeceğimi bilmiyorum
bir
ayrıca değişiklikler
ama burada
bir
içinde
Diyelimki
tüm ekibe yakın olmak için doğrudan
[Müzik]
iyi
Ey
[Müzik]
hepsi kadar
şimdi
[Müzik]
tuzun
s
hiçbir şeysiz
Y
dır-dir
H
bizim
Görüşürüz
Y
veya
ekinlerinin hızı
ve eylemler
[Müzik]
ve
Bence
Ey
[Müzik]
Evet
Ben
ve o nasıldı
onlar çimenler
[Müzik]
daha kararlı
şüphesiz
benim meyvelerim
onun yeri için
bir
[Müzik]
bir tek
Bence
[Müzik]
Peki
veya
[Müzik]
[Alkış]